ambos candidatos querrán verse
tranquilos y serenos para el debate
televisivo de este 2022 lo opuesto a la
confusión y tensión de hace cinco años
siempre te inclinas ante alemánia las
grandes empresas los bancos
el equipo de marín lepén reconoce que
fue demasiado agresiva cuáles son los
errores a evitar
no tiene sentido enfadarse tienes que
dar una respuesta mesurada de vender
políticas e ideas y demostrar que puede
ser presidente
una trampa que van a querer evitar son
los sarcasmos mutuos como en 2017 cuando
se enfrentaron cara a cara por los
detalles de dos empresas francesas
estás leyendo notas que no son de las
dos empresas que mencionas una es de
telecomunicaciones y la otra hace
turbinas y materiales industriales
serían estilete el equipo de manuel
macro sabe que no debe parecer superior
separamos arrogante hacer preguntas en
un momento tan crucial como el debate
presidencial para mostrar que hay detrás
del manto de banalidades que marín diop
en ha estado escondiendo dura
marín le pen según admitió ella misma
llegó al debate en 2017 sintiéndose
cansada y mal preparada la posición de
siete tours ayudó esta vez creo que han
decidido calmarse ella querrá parecer
competente creíble no perdida en sus
notas y presidencial y evitar ser vista
como arrogante como si le estuviera
dando una lección a alguien
el duelo fue eléctrico hasta el último
segundo hasta cinco años esta vez una
diferencia clave es que en manual macro
tendrá cinco años de decisiones
políticas para defender